the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
welcome to the 2022 summer chess classic
part of a series of tournaments that we
hire have here at the st louis chess
club that brings together some of the
best players in the world they're not
quite top 10 they're not quite top 20
but we will have some of the top 50 top
100 best players in the world
participating here trying to become that
elite chess player status and to bring
you all of the action we are here in
studio b i am grand master alejandro
ramirez here with grand master christian
carrillo alejandro always a pleasure to
be here in studio b for the first time
with you yes absolutely we have some
renovations going on at the st louis
chess club we have a great amount of
things happening including a new studio
that will be unveiled later so we're
still working on it we're in the temp
studio right now but shortly we have a
lot of action coming for you as you can
see even the play hall is new we are
playing uh right around the corner from
the chess club as the chess club has a
lot of activities and construction
happening speaking of that let's see
what is going on in this tournament
let's see what the players are at the
summer chess classic we have two round
robins for you let's start with the a
group we have some of the best players
here headlining this event two 2700s yu
yang yi from china who has been in the
united states for a few months right now
and sam savion who just became a 2700 at
the american cup his last showing here
in st louis a very successful one
defeating wesley saw and obtaining that
coveted super gm status and a couple of
players in the top 50 we have your
student grisha oparin and ray robson
absolutely and we have also benjamin
gledura representing hungary 2644 a
student actually at webster university
just like aram hacobian from armenia
2615 two very talented players here in
st louis jonas dear from a denmark a
player that we see for the first time
here in st louis ilya smith nicolas te
odoro that is your student alejandro at
st louis university and abi mishra
representing the united states at 25 35
and how about the b group alejandro yeah
the big grip is a mix of talent you have
a lot of collegiate chess in the b group
we have some in the a group but
definitely a lot in the b group uh
headlining the event is going to be
misha antipope who is your student he is
now going to mizzou at mississippi
university misha he got relegated from
uh the spring chess classic he played in
the a group in that one unfortunately
did not play very well and right now he
will be spearheading the big group yeah
he's a highest rated player but there's
a lot of talent here joe jian ciao is
another player that is from china but
has been living in america for quite a
few years now he normally travels around
playing opens he's been 2600 more than
once and he is going to be a tough
competitor john burke goes to webster
university camille dragoon goes to
university of texas at rio grande valley
guillermo vazquez goes to university of
texas at dallas tigran tunian is an
armenian player who's making a bit of a
tour around america so good to have him
here uh youngster christopher you is
actually too young to go to college but
the other players are college level and
college age nicholas czecho goes to yale
jj ali marandi actually just graduated
from st louis university he'll be
attending uc san diego on a phd program
very soon and brandon jacobson is also
in college although it escapes me which
one of the ivy leagues he's going to
absolutely and the tournament format
alejandro can you tell us a bit about
that it's straightforward it is a 10
player round robin 90 minutes for the
first 40 moves 30 minutes for the rest
of the game and a 30 second increment
all throughout so pretty standard
classical tournament uh double two round
robins of course each one of uh 10
players and the schedule is equally easy
absolutely we're going to be playing
every single day from today thursday
june 2nd all the way to june 10th we
will be starting the actual tournament
the games will be starting at 1 p.m
our show will actually start two and a
half hours later at 3 30 p.m central
time the last round friday june 10th is
going to start two hours earlier 11am
for the actual games start time and 1 30
pm for the show and if necessary we will
be having a playoffs which will start at
5pm
also tell us a bit about social media
alejandro absolutely please join us in
all of our social medias but especially
if you're watching this broadcast on
twitch please feel free to subscribe
donate all of the money that we get here
is helpful for the same with chess club
but specifically for every 75 dollars
that we get through these donations
through these subs we'll be able to give
this back to the community we'll be
sponsoring a full semester of chess
classes for kids talented kids around
the st louis area chess classes with
grand masters absolutely alejandro i
think varus and kobe and our good friend
here in st louis teaches a lot of those
classes so you get prime time coaching
for some of the best coaches in the
world absolutely so
thank you for joining the stream and
thank you for all of your help and with
uh
let's nothing to do let's take a look at
the pairings and see how we're starting
this tournament up we already have a few
results for today in round number one uh
sam savion is currently playing against
abimeshwara i think this is uh one of
the key matches of the day because sam
just became 2700 and of course misha
zero years of age is a very interesting
player yu yang yi who's playing against
benjamin ledour is also an extremely
interesting match it's one of the
highest rated matches in the event elias
miran is playing against jonas bier
which is actually very interesting and
the two results that we already have
nicolas deodoro drew against adam
jacobian very easily and grigorio paren
also was unable to prove any kind of
advantage against ray robson these two
players you see them right there they
drew their game to start the event that
is a slow start for uh these two uh
players but a very stable uh start and
how about the b group what the key
pairings do we have in that one
the big group is full of talent uh john
berg against tigran harutonian is
actually a very interesting one for me
burke has been improving a lot in the
last year and tigran is as i said doing
this tour of america i think it's going
to be great uh jj ali miranda against
christopher u has become more or less a
classic matchup around st louis and i
run a lot of tournaments in america uh
they've played each other many times
guillermo vasquez playing against
antipov it's actually a collegiate
classic as well uh so as this checker
against jacobson and uh dragon again
jojong ciao i think
uh the highest
rating per average yeah average of the
day players in the b group and actually
this is a very interesting one we've
seen camille here at the st louis chess
club quite a number of times right in
this classical events we've never seen
zhu zhang chow here at the st louis
chess club what do you know about zhu
yeah he's actually a very uh positional
player he's been playing chess
in america for quite a while but he
hasn't ventured to the saint louis chess
club until just now he uh like many
players in the tournament actually just
comes back from the chicago open uh that
happened a couple of days ago
in wheeling illinois nowhere near
chicago and it was a fascinating
tournament joe jin chow was one of the
players that did well he was always near
the top boards and his opponent camille
dragoon actually had a bit of a disaster
even though he recovered near the last
few rounds he just lost early
against weaker rated players and lost a
lot of rating so certainly it was
something that he wants to wipe out of
his mind and come back fully into this
event and those open tournaments are so
taxing on the energy level of these
players because they actually play two
games a day here at saint louis chess
club you get the luxurious treatment of
a chess player you play only one game a
day a very nice and relaxed tournament
in that regard in the open tournaments
here in the united states playing two
games a day
so taxing on the energy levels yeah it's
really tough uh people always always
underestimate how tough uh double rounds
are compared to single rounds that's the
way we call them if you play two games a
day or one game a day
especially in tournaments like the
chicago open where we actually had the
exact same time control uh there was no
uh skipping of the second time control
put it that way uh so that was kind of
interesting but sticking with that game
we can probably go straight into the
chess because they do have an
interesting position and we might as
well start with that because today the b
group is giving us the thrills on spills
compared to the a group uh as far as far
as interesting chess goes and let's see
how we got there so i'm actually curious
one started off with e4 c5 okay
knight to c6 queen to c7 and now this
idea of playing g3 now we oh my goodness
we know that the main line usually goes
something along the lines of bishop to
e3 sometimes f4 yeah we've seen yeah
camille this position camille actually
played against me in the summer classic
uh bishop e3 queen f3 right so we
actually debated this in a previous
summer classic that i was participating
in and camille beat me that time uh so
he is familiar with e3 a6 queen f3 which
became very trendy i played bishop d6 we
played a long theoretical line and we
played an interesting game but he ended
up beating me yeah g3 of course is the
other way was one of many many ways of
dealing with the position much more
positional than some of the other
attempts much more positional but at the
same time in general it doesn't give why
the best chances to get an opening
advantage or at least
this is um yeah the current you know end
of the line i used to think like that
but i actually spent because i played
this as black i had to spend some time
looking at it it is more poisonous than
it seems and i wouldn't be surprised a
lot of people
are employed in the repertoire but it is
not the most attacking and it's not the
most direct so some people like to leave
it in the back burner but as the
timeline of the player that wants to get
double-edged positions it is
particularly annoying because in some
positions what is just better absolutely
and not not the kind of battery where
both sides are attacking the kind of
battery where you just have a slight
edge and you can't do much they use your
counter play as black uh when white gets
a long castle yeah exactly right yeah
yeah so it's a little it's a little more
i'm not going to say boring but it is a
little more quiet as that approach so
let's see how we got to uh especially on
a7 yeah queen to e2 obviously hinting at
the idea of potentially playing e5 later
on in the game castle bishop to d to not
bishop to a3 you don't want to exchange
the dark square uh bishops because uh
that's just going to diminish the
potential for your attack later on on
the king's side yeah b5 e5 immediately
taking advantage of the fact that the
long diagonal has opened up for the
bishop one g2 now actually i'm looking
at the position and they just miss the
move e5 because it does look devastating
for black's position take take knight to
h7 i mean knight h7 is a very bad
symptom right you have to keep the
knight close to your king right because
otherwise i have a feeling some bishop
takes h6
is going to come on i'm actually i'm
actually curious because
and by the way we are actually not using
the engine so we're just guessing for
this one we will not be using the engine
throughout the event we want uh to keep
you guys guessing but we want to keep us
guessing as well knight d7 now
what would you do at this point
alejandro would you go knight to e4 try
to get another piece into the attack or
would you
let's start with bishop takes h6 just
just for fun right that's for fun it's
they're not our pcs yeah that's the best
part of it but it also might just win
exactly you have to go to h8 if you go
to h7 i have a feeling yeah that's just
going to help me there's no there's no
reason to help white here right yeah and
oh by the way
i was taking a look at rook f6 but i
couldn't make it work why not take
stakes
and now with the bishop on e4 i have a
feeling that after queen to h5 there's
not a good way to defend the polar
nation that's what i thought but you
have bishop b3
yeah this bishop comes out of nowhere
and actually ends up defending so i
couldn't actually make
this rook f6 ideas work but of course we
you you they're so attractive right
i couldn't make any of this work to be
honest so
let's assume you're actually going to go
like a normal person right
that's also a problem yeah that that
that yeah i mean you're just down
material yeah okay to be down a pawn in
the end game with the worst structure
probably you're not going to save this
with black no probably not oh also king
i mean let's be honest king h7 is a
little psychotic exactly all right let's
go king 28
how do we continue
you could just attack this pawn with
like queen
queen right quinn h5 the thing about
queen h5 i understand there's king g7
understand his king h7 understands
all kinds of stuff but even queen i know
queen e5 actually drops to c6 knight
yeah exactly yeah that's a problem you
cannot do that i hope you're just going
to pick up and then take on c6 so you
cannot do that you have to go something
long lines yeah
but since i haven't sacrificed as much
material here rookie one might just win
because i just think
you could do that but i think rookie one
was also good enough like i like this
it's where's the knight you don't have
the bishop where's the bishop going
actually
yeah i don't think that black saves this
no this looks uh
um what about king to g7
yeah that thing both yeah the question
is you have better than a draw here you
would assume yes right that's a rook f6
is a move tempting option
all right let's see
it's not okay
so we might as well take take take you
have to take otherwise you get
checkmated yeah yeah that's clear so you
take one f6
i have options here
i have so many options it's crazy
um
how do we start
that's the question all right let's take
this pawn
and then see how to continue after this
i can even just play a quiet move such
as rook 31 rookie one even rook f1 is
dangerous knight d5
yeah rook d1 is dangerous where kf1 is
dangerous i mean black is never better
no i mean there's no way
there's
okay let's let's get back to the game so
this is the reason that the knight
didn't go to d7 he saw 97
yes h6 is coming i'm going to die i i
want to keep the knight close to my key
yeah yeah i i agree knight h7 is a more
human move
a4 a4 is the type of move that's easy to
underestimate because you you feel that
e5
will be followed up with a blow on the
king side i love this move i love a4
actually a4 is a very good move now the
idea is that if you take
uh you allow not only that you're
creating some weaknesses yeah your
structure but also you're allowing my
rook
to get into the to the attack via g4 via
h4 no that's that's really nice h6
very nicely coming into play and this is
more or less one of the only pieces
outside of let's say the knight on b3
that is not playing an active role into
the attack yeah i really love this move
a4 now the question of course is what if
you go b4 and why didn't he play before
he because he did take on a4 i think
yeah i think i think this works knight
to b5 so if you take take setting up
this pin on the long diagonal
you have to play bishop b7 you have to
probably defend and what if i continue
yeah you can even play queen c4 honestly
you know you cannot take on c6 because
this is kind of bad but perhaps this is
just the easy way
i am a pawn up after and the bishop gets
to d6 exactly
is brutal good enough right yeah it's
just winning it's just two connected
passports on the queen side and i mean
the knight was somewhere useful
then maybe but with the knight on h7
there's no way black is compensation
where is the knight god coming
g5 you're going to get harassed with h4
yeah you don't have enough control on
the light square there's something on
the lines of knight knight g6 but no no
no no no no no no that's too sad no i i
like a4 a lot because i think before
that moment didn't work so he ends up
taking that might be the move that he
missed this idea this idea of a4 yeah
they take bishop to b7 rook to c4
to g4 rook to c4 is also an option rook
to c8 knight to e4 every single piece
yeah it's just coming to the attacks
playing a beautiful role into the attack
now give me the pawn but whoa at the
cost of
coming on the long diagonals setting up
the ideas of queen g4 queen takes g7
knight
everything is coming your way yeah the
the the move queen e5 that was just
played
it's kind of like forced bravery you
have to you have to take on e5 you have
to pray a little that you don't get made
it but if you don't take on e5 you're as
good as dead because the knight is
coming to jump to d6 you it hits every
piece the bishop the rook the knight is
a monster knight f6 is also a problem so
you just take on e5 and you hope that it
works out for you it doesn't matter if
it doesn't you pray you pray there's
nothing you can do about it the problem
is that i have a feeling
white's moves are also quite simple uh
well where's the win right
that is the the main question there's so
many tempting options in this position
if i'm trying to calculate
like let's try to analyze this as grand
master first like what are the candidate
moves right like u4 queen g4 attacks
lens checkmate
knight f6 doesn't really work but i
still consider it bishop g7 i consider
then if none of the direct ways work you
start considering ibc5
because it attacks the bishop it also
threatens knight d7 so this kind of hops
are something that grand masters
consider very quickly
all of this like looks very logical so
we always start calculating the most
forcing which is queen g4 right g4
attacks g7 it's checkmate it's amazing
it's mainly one and the main idea behind
this move why we calculated first is
that we see that after f6 you can just
simply take on f6
f6 probably just uh and destroys black's
position so
f6 not possible what is another way to
defend against uh g7 interposing
something yeah this diagonal i think 95
yeah 95 might be the issue right so 95
that comes with tempo that's the problem
that's the problem it's a nice tempo
because the rook is hanging
i'm not taking it with the knight
obviously i can probably tell i think
this is fine for a blog maybe more than
fine right remember we did sacrifice
upon to get here yep
bishop before knight f2 is an is a
threat it's like a very real threat yep
so i don't think i have time to do
anything nope nope this doesn't matter
g4 we eliminate we cancel that i don't
think that's that's going to be the move
what else well knight c5 looks very
logical and actually knight c5 was
played he's on the board yeah the last
piece that wasn't you mentioned it you
mentioned it yourself that mp3 wasn't
part of the attack it's the last thing
preventing us from killing our opponent
so let's bring him into the game and by
the way how are we doing on time 23
minutes for dragoon building up a nice
time yeah differential 13 minutes and 50
seconds and counting for
who jojo's to defend accurately yeah and
it's hard to do so what what move are oh
21 they are so far away from mu 40. that
is a very good question uh and they do
not they do get the 30 second increments
starting from move one
but up to 40 i mean yeah that they're on
their own right now you're on your own
with the black pieces trying to defend
the position in which every single white
piece is attacking yeah yeah
everything's a threat the every single
piece that you have in this position is
running something and it's very hard to
play against such initiative because
you're not creating threats right xp7 is
a big one knight b7 is a huge threat
because knight d6 follows knight d7 is
just equally as good of a threat
honestly
so let's say you try to defend this d7
square yeah rook the e8
it's one of those moves that is
definitely high on the praying schedule
like
man like rook f7 might work queen g4
might just be much stronger now what is
happening here i mean the chances black
survive this are low but
i mean i could i would consider just
taking on b7 and going queen g4 setting
up this nice yeah
and the difference here is that you
don't have
knight e5 right it's a very big
difference
you just take
night anywhere knight f6 so if you go e5
you might have to there's so many things
there's some there's so many things
right
man i don't believe in this
although
probably just a simple knight c5 is good
but i'm wondering if i have something
better i just didn't find it
i mean i'm trying to be fancy like
knight d6 rook takes bishop takes e5 but
then this is how i get let's do it
like this yeah maybe why not because if
you take with the queen i have feelings
f6 is also an idea maybe not immediately
but later on in the game for sure it
will be
i don't like putting the queen on that
diagonal but maybe i have to and just
try to go queen to g6 here right now
this might hold actually
precisely because i was mentioning this
knight f6 discovery check the problem is
that knight takes f6 comes and that's an
attack on the queen
and in many cases i think black's going
to be happy even if you have to take
with the queen to get the two rogues yes
yes so let's go back a little bit let's
go back a little bit sure so we go rook
fd8 here this looks very logical because
i mean it's not the move you want to
make
in terms of the f7 pawn but it is the
only move to connect all your pieces
together
um
continue the attack i don't see a
killing blow but by the way do i have to
take on b7 no no no i was just putting
in there to drag the queen so what if we
started with queen to g here i was
thinking knight e5 95 but i think that
doesn't work right i take take and i can
take on b7 because now your rook is high
your rook is hanging that's very nice
and the knight takes on f7 is a threat
so you don't have time to do it
is protected so if you go f5 i'm feeling
i'm going to be able to set up some
checkmating idea yeah queen of silence
mate we have seven queen yeah yeah
that's that's good enough
yeah that's actually great so start with
the move bishop c3
it just makes everything much stronger
and if you yeah this looks crazy g4 you
have to defend it with e5
no but that's just disgusting i think
that's the only move in the position
close to it at least if you go g6
96 just like this
no no yeah now you have to go e5 but e5
is
now i can go knight d7 i mean you can go
any number of things knight d7 wins
i was very close to making rook f7 work
well why not yeah because you take queen
e6 and now
i'm like one check away from winning i
don't know if i have it
i don't know if i have this check but if
it exists it's made something must be
happening right now right like bishop b4
must win or something but i can't find
it
it might not be winning really
i don't see it if this saves black maybe
first of all even this move even queen
g6 is really strong it's most likely
just winning take
i am just a rook dog
yeah you might think it's just a rook
that but it's like
it's such a bad position for black
and i'm hearing that we have some
blunders alejandro yeah this looks
really bad we're gonna we're gonna leave
camilo thinking but we think that if you
just play he's just in a nearly winning
position because we can't find a defense
and a zoo with only nine minutes while
he has a titanic task ahead of himself
yeah we're being told to check up
blunder so we might want to check that
game out
uh it's in the b group
i don't know who he's playing he's
playing a jacobson brandon oh what is
going on in this game what are these
knights doing running around very good
question
what on earth is going on so many pieces
around the white king
yeah but how do we get to it it's kind
of the same first of all how are we
doing material wise uh i think it's
what's up a pawn why is up a pawn black
has the option of taking the exchange
with knight takes d1 it does i don't
know if i want to take it though but
probably you don't so
my guess is that the first thing we need
to calculate is some knight takes on h3
yes i think we calculated that first
right takes on h3 doesn't matter just to
make sure that there's no i don't think
it matters which one you do here
you take on h3
do you take on h3 or i want to look at
take on h3 first just to get it out of
the way so you have to take you have to
take i take back
and i think
you're doing a nice checkmate with queen
h2q yeah i think you have to go rook e2
because if you go rook
d2 perhaps rook d2 also somehow no no
my main point is you cannot go queen d2
right queen d2 is met with bishop d4 d4
and this is actually just a win because
yeah i don't have queen f2 but i do have
just simple g
followed by g1 getting another queen and
i'm probably going to generally yeah the
queens are pretty good two queens are
good one queen is very strong two queens
are even better
so you cannot retreat like this but i
think rookie two
holds everything right it does
kind of don't see it you can try to go
rookie
but now we're just fishing i think we
are yeah yeah let's go back a little bit
maybe you take one h3 and go g2 like you
mentioned
and now the idea being that if you do
take on g3 maybe i have this move queen
to cheat
you might
how does this continue i still don't see
the killing blow so
ah but now we don't have a good no
you have to play
the only way to defend this bishop is
with queen d2 because you go rogue d2
you drop e1 if you drop go to e2 you
drop the rook entirely
fortunately there's still a knight on f4
yeah so there's boom boom so
you have to go queen d2 it's the only
move that actually defends
um
this bishop successfully
thing is now what
well i have a lot of easy
check your booking f1 though right after
king 2f1 unfortunately you don't have
any follow-up checks no i don't if you
don't have any follow-up checks you are
a piece down yeah maybe
a good way of doing things is instead of
going bishop defaults that are not h3
and you have to go king each one i don't
think that's a choice packing f1 maybe
looking f1 queen h2
no that's mate 1 g2 i cannot take it so
it's a good point that might just win
actually queen to g1 i don't think it
um
stopped
just made actually yeah there is no good
way to stop that
go to h1 and here i was thinking bishop
f2 thing is i forgot that rook g1
actually pins my um
my queen
so i can't i can't go like knight g to
queen h3
it just doesn't work at all
unfortunately queen h3 is illegal yeah
so i don't know
i actually don't know where the killing
blow is so
and
let's remember our uh let's remind our
audience we are actually not using
engines these engines right now which i
think at this point they they kind of
figured it out
[Laughter]
all right so g2 bishop takes g2
and maybe it's not knight takes issue by
the way i mean yeah we're just we're
just we're just kind of guessing at this
point yeah perhaps just simply
what do you do
i'm after gonna take it slow i'm gonna
be honest with you
the move c5 looks so sketchy like i just
i just noticed what bla white's last
move was and the idea of cutting this
bishop
from the defense is such a crazy idea
the idea was going to d6
knight to f2
yeah this bishop c5 c5 i mean what's the
point of this no i mean c5 he wants to
go to c7 yeah your bomb wants to go to
c7 but you're not gonna get there
i mean you're definitely not going to
get there this bishop is just out of the
game for one important tempo i like your
idea actually of taking on h3g2 or q1 i
don't know rookie sorry it's i don't
know if it's the only idea but it's
pretty compelling because i mean you are
hitting the rook if i do continue with
rook to f1
you're saying that okay but knight e2
looks
deadly that's fine you gave a check but
then what yes that's more than check
yeah because bishop e5 is also yeah
bishop b5 is an issue now with the rook
uh playing an active role into the
attack you can support bishop to e5
um yeah yeah maybe r38 might be
somewhat a problem
because if
you have to lose a tempo yeah you cannot
i don't think you can take on e8 you
probably have to take on but
but how do you defend all the threats
there are just so many pieces hovering
around the king d1 rookie one rookie two
queen g3
g3 no everything's a thread
boom boom boom it's nice knight on a4
and bishop on b6 are simply not playing
on the defense right yep yeah this is
terrible
maybe this is the way to go
and how are we doing on time 12 minutes
for chekka
he spent six minutes on this last move
c5 and 19 minutes to find
the killing blow right now for brandon
jacobson yeah no engines so we don't
know what it is but we expect it to be
knight takes h3 we might also think
that
there could be something i mean you
could even start with rookie honestly or
to e8 first yeah
yeah
i mean the same idea applies i am trying
to take on h3 and play g2
um and i can take it slow it seems like
it might be the better way of doing
things
just an easier way right because now you
have so many threats
involving knight takes h3 and g2
so what if i go c6
no but here i do that right i take
and i think i think i do it the other
way around i think i took only one first
[Music]
i think i took only one here you have to
take only one knight h3 and g3 the point
is that bishop f2 knight h3 is probably
working for black
bishop
yeah bishop f2 and now like oh you can't
even take on f1 attack on everyone but
probably not everything's made
knight takes is also good uh the idea
being that if you uh yeah yeah do take
with the rook i do have this extra track
that's just me
queen is going to land on g2 with
devastating consequences um okay so
yeah this seems good looks a bit busted
here not gonna lie all right let's
continue
our uh
around the horn for this one uh the big
group
we're going to continue with this game
between vasquez
and misha antipov
um
well first of all one thing that i'm
seeing is that antipope only has four
minutes left
right if i learned something about your
student from the summer classic or the
spring classic actually green classic it
was the man loves time travel he does
indeed um and it definitely doesn't help
his results
he just played this move e5
which i have to say
it looks quite dangerous for
a variety of ideas it's very provoking
yeah and by the way we do have a result
alimorandi versus christopher eu ended
in an uneventful draw
yeah i can't say anything happened in
that game so we're going to leave it
alone perfect all right so
what's the situation here here alejandro
i mean my original impression is that e5
is such a weakening move
but
also it's such a strange move because it
opens up
now you have the idea of queensland
something landing on f8 let's go queen
to see it yeah here probably rook did it
holds everything together right rook to
d8 and you're just saying that you have
absolutely every single score
which is true i think it is true and
that d4 is hanging right so you don't
have time to do this
yes
this definitely sounds like
so e5 maybe
correct timing question mark
it's still a little scary to play but i
don't see a refutation to it because it
is a bit sad for white to lose that
night
uh anchored on d4 right the knight south
post on d4 is beautifully nice
so what if you take take knight and now
you just go back to f3 but in the worst
case
even bishop takes f3 probably equalizer
what are we playing for i think just
equality just equality right for black
yeah the king is too weak
i agree with you i don't think that i
don't think that black is playing for an
advantage no i think that bishop f3
might be called for worse structure you
do have the best let's say an active
bishop it has a better nice central
active bishop better let's say better
than the knight yes i think but nothing
else yeah you don't have anything to
attack either underneath threes on the
dark square pawn on b2 is in a dark
square
well chess is an equal game starting
from the beginning and maybe
construction is more or less equal as
well yep
um perfect all right vasquez on tip of
this one seems to be going
into a peaceful territory how about the
game between john burke and harutunian
let's take a look uh the game between
savian and miesha might finish in a
second but there's no real need to
change okay we'll just finish this one i
think this is the last game that we have
in group b
and uh this one is looking as if well
black is up upon
uh
upper pawn
are you sure
never mind
my counting days are over
the accounting career is done yeah
my accounting days are over
it's been a good run
you cannot take on b7 or b5 if you take
on b5 then you just drop
a rook and if you do take on b7 i have a
feeling you're probably going to get
challenged
if you do get
your king on the h file i have this
extra check picking up a pawn quite an
important pawn so probably you don't
want that and if you do get on
if you do go on f1
check
and where's the main
okay
that's another check i go back
i think and even if it's not an
immediate mate i can just simply take on
h5
with checkmating threats
although apply queen c queen of five and
pretend right and pretend that maybe you
can hold maybe actually the quality in
this one um
it might be equal actually then again
i'm still not convinced but you know
let's say let's say it is
yeah but let's say it is it doesn't
really matter because there must be a
way to checkmate right yeah there must
be some some way so no no you don't i
don't think he wants to take no you
never take the queen is so powerful but
what do you do i mean there's rook d7
just exchanged
it will always just lead to a draw right
i don't think that they taking h7 queen
d5 solidifies the queen
although how easy it is for black to
make this draw exactly i still have this
extra pawn yeah
and some pawning games will be lost
i assume not if i trade on f5 though
because the structure still ruined
although i don't know the question is
whose king gets first right because i
have a forking f3 or three king e4 let's
make a stupid move like b6 sure b6 queen
f5 take take and now the idea that you
were mentioning is to just go f4
centralize the king
do i have enough time to go and protect
let's see it's funny because there's two
big questions right what if you start
running and the other big question is
what if you go g6 so i can go here bom
bom and then you start running you got
just in time but not but i have one more
one more tempo yeah yeah one more bullet
one more bullet in the gun that's all
you need the game penetrates
yeah wherever you go i'm going to go
opposite direction
and this is just a win
white yeah
so i don't know how you cannot do that
we got there pretty far
well we we did the move b6 which is kind
of a funny move and probably a very bad
move but
all right let's continue with this
because this is quite an interesting one
what if you don't go f6 i think in g6
uh-huh i thought that was a good move
sure
because i think that if you take twice
what's actually lost
and if you take once
it's also lost
white
yeah
because you have the
far away path far away past spawn and i
have double b points you have to take
both of them
that's very unfortunate actually
so what we're saying is that if you take
take and you continue taking you do have
two pawns and i only have one
but you're going to be spending a lot
more time getting this one then i'm
going to be spending getting both of
these parts yeah and then most likely
i'm going to be first
most likely we're not sure we're not
sure but but most likely our experience
says
our gm experience
is saying that it's winning which might
be very wrong i would be surprised not
winning though okay so you have to go h5
because if you go k4 i go king g4 and
you're not winning anything
this is winning though so i go here you
take i go here you take
okay yeah you're you're winning
it's because of the double pawns right
you are winning yeah the double pawns
force white to
to capture on i don't have the c5 so you
don't have the c5 square actually with
the pawn on b7 maybe this is not winning
uh it's winning anyway because you play
b6 at some point like when the king's on
d3 you just play
well the king is not on d3 that's the
thing you don't get on you don't get on
d3 yeah maybe but with the pawn on b6 is
uh winning with the pawn on b7 probably
not because i have king to c5 that's
very theoretical all right but okay why
does the one pressing that's what we
decided you can go into the
queen end game with rook d8 and queen d5
yes or you can keep the rook alive maybe
something like rook d7
but the moment you play into that you
have to be careful of black having his
own counter play rookie one type of idea
sorry problems let's jump into
the
a group yeah
a group these we have the game between
samsevi and abhimanyu mishra they are
currently
uh in a position where clearly black is
up upon
but that's about the only good thing
that's happening in this position
because every piece of his is passive
uh especially that gigantic pawn on d7
um
it's still it's not easy for white to
penetrate the reference c5
it's kind of controlled by the bishop on
d7 and you're never really going to take
that part on a5
right and whenever even if you do get
the pawn on c6 uh you're probably going
to exchange too many pieces yeah that's
the issue right like if you take on c6
with the bishop ever you're trading off
my problem which is the dark the light
squared bishop
so it's pretty equal
right but the only thing that i'm seeing
in this position and
this applies we've we've seen this in
the game the first game that we analyzed
the one between dragoon and zhu zhanchao
he was focusing a lot on the king side
but then he created a second weakness on
the queen side with the move a4 that's
very attractive for move a4 now we're
seeing the same thing in this position
black has
very good defensive methods
for your attack on the c6 pawn but
all of its pieces are on the queen side
now can we direct our forces against
your other weakness on the king side
which is the pawn on f5 that's the only
thing that i'm seeing
let's go g4 you have to i think that if
you want to play for when you have to go
g4 yeah
you have to reinforce the defense of
that pawn right
if you don't then probably i take and i
create this past pawn with on on on e5
yeah i don't think that i want to give
you the e6 tricks
it feels yeah it feels wrong to allow
uh taking on f5 and then you having to
for example let's just play a couple of
a couple a couple of bad moves it's not
even easy to make this
take e6
take bishop to d3 yeah attacking the
rock on a6 you have to
drop back and then after rook takes c6
first of all you just immediately lose a
piece of piece yeah
i mean there is a check but
let's say we hide the king on g2 first
but you get the ideas right you don't
have to do it right away
there will be a lot of distracting ideas
that it's not easy for black to meet
maybe e6 doesn't win immediately but at
some point it will you can start with
king g2 you can start with king
somewhere exactly and it's not like
black maybe even f4 maybe an f4 black
doesn't have a good way to reinforce the
position whereas you see that white only
has an issue if the king is being
checked down the line move it out of the
check uh beforehand so let's go with g6
well i don't think we're going to see
anything i think that bishop a4 is the
threefold repetition is it i think so so
oh we might see yeah we might see a
three drawing this one yeah okay they're
checking uh we see a big money right now
on the screen checking the score sheet
seeing if they do indeed that's amazing
that's a great start for the youngster
though they're great with black pieces
again once again savion
2700 yep it's great great draw great kid
can play i think we determined that in
the previous one we were both very
impressed with the way that he played in
the spring chess classic uh won the
tournament had a great event
and that is exactly why he's playing in
the a group in this one because he's by
far the lowest rated player in the event
but he earned
the spot by winning the b group in the
spring chase classic that's right so
all right what else do we have in the
air group because this one will just be
this one peter's out in to a draw
actually we can
probably see a big money right now
asking for the arbiter
checking the scoresheet right now
and he's probably going to stop the
clock and the thing is black really
cannot try for a weight yes all right
don't don't actually make the move yeah
oh oh he's showing it oh there we go
yeah so for those that are confused the
correct way of claiming a draw is to
actually stop the clock
and control the rv yeah call the arbiter
show the arbiter not your opponent
uh which move you want to play and say
that that move would make the game a
three-fold repetition
and
the arbiter will certify usually arbiter
just asks the opponent first if they
think this is correct they don't do that
in this tournament because there's a no
draw offer rule
but normally you're it counts as a draw
for first second would have the chance
to accept it but here it's obvious it's
a three-fold repetition and the players
just agree with it the arbiter obviously
is watching the games closely shout out
to
my cummer international arbitrary
mycomer who is uh proceeding over this
tournament so that's another draw in the
a group we have a lot of draws today to
start a tournament let's take a look at
what's remaining there because i think
it's been a while since we looked at the
yu yang yi ledura game i don't know if
we looked at it at all
and it's such a heavyweight matchup
what's going on here glendora seems to
be up a pawn hazel upon and i'm trying
to understand whether there is enough
compensation now we do see an immediate
bishop takes d4 follow uh followed up by
knight to e6
is that enough let's find out there are
two ways of taking the most natural is
to take with the rook i don't think you
want to split your pawns with pawn takes
d4 and uh union eic has not gone for it
to play the movie f3 but i think that's
great but i think it's precisely because
of this i don't see a follow-up no you
can try to take take and rook to c5 but
i have an easy difference with rook to
e7 and this is just going to be a game
for two results
at least and probably you're just losing
it might actually just be lost because
there are a few threads and you might
think that you have the clever move f4
here oh f4 yeah you take take on f5 but
i was wondering if you just played b6
and you just say your king is a little
too funny you can also go this
this is pretty good but you know check
check take one h7 whatever i think b6
just finishes the game
because you you can't go into the point
you cannot take because take take and
king to d7 and just actually first yeah
you're actually way way way faster yeah
just one thing
wow good enough yeah that's good enough
that's good enough that is true
one tempo is good enough indeed uh he
cannot do that and after b6 probably has
to go to d5
yeah but then we have the same ideas i
just gained the tempo and you can also
try
you could also consider going c6 and
exit on this side c6 is an option yeah
yeah so now he's lost he's playing the
move f3 let's catch up with the players
f3 bishop f6 on the board so it seems
that yuya yusuke is going to settle down
and suffer down a pawn he has plenty of
activity right now the rook c1 is nice
the knight on c5 is nice he has a lot of
things going for him let's put it that
way so he certainly has some
compensation for the pawn but it's
obvious that the pawn is strong that
black is better and is pushing for the
win
all right let's jump to this interesting
matchup uh battle of experience versus
youth uh smearing versus beer we are
only 16 years of age from denmark
smearing uh quite an experienced player
at some point we just stopped saying the
age was just saying experience that's
right just experience it's all good of
course of course yeah i mean for those
people that might be following chess not
so regularly
or maybe just got into it you might
never have heard of the name elias
mirren but this is quite a legend in the
chess world i mean this is a player that
reached
super high rankings he's always been an
open tournament player you might not
know him from close tournaments i played
him actually in an open tournament i
think it was in greece 2000 and i don't
remember exactly yeah he's just
everywhere right he plays open certainly
he does literally everywhere america
europe asia you name it he goes uh but
happy to have him here i think it's his
first time at the chess club so it's
good to see him here it is yeah
he's been gunning for uh for a while
yeah for a while a competitive
tournament a lot of people want to play
in this one but glad to get smearing in
uh definitely a legend of the game and
right now he seems to be defending
a pawn down position where honestly he's
defending more because of the king
position than fukusa he's down upon
because the pawns are pretty irrelevant
but this should be pretty
pretty drawn i think so yeah yes but at
the same time it's probably going to be
a race um
i want to get my point way too
yeah and also this we're coming to c2 so
so let's let's try to do this let's
block the move right a for you he just
played rook to c5 yeah right five makes
sense rook to c5 cutting the king it's
very important that you don't allow the
king to uh pass the midline and get
closer to the c3 pawn because
i'm not too worried about giving up
maybe one maybe even two points on this
side
as long as i can create the connection
between the rook and the pawn from the
side
then it's probably going to be winning
so i do like this move rook to c5 now a4
seems like an automatic almost
and yeah i don't i mean you never play
king g6 i mean a lot i think a lot of
our viewers are like why not keen g6 and
defend your ones but you're not winning
like this this this three versus two
never win and what it's gonna end up
happening is that black trades the a
pawn for the c pawn
and and the game just ends in a draw
it's all about these two pawns it's all
yeah it's all about those two nobody
really cares about the king's head right
now so roxy 5a4 makes a lot of sense and
i think that he's going to just play
rook a5 sure which is the usual way you
handle this position is you want to put
the rook behind the pawn
that's what they teach you in grand
master school in some school but this
looks pretty drawn right because i mean
you just get my pawn to c5 i'm not
really sure how you make progress i
don't even know if i want to get the
pawn to c5 i just want to do it because
i'm lazy i'm a lazy gm i don't want to
calculate anything i just want to i just
want to one i just wonder if my setup
with pawn on c5 is typical an opponent
f3 is just a draw all right so i'll give
you a check yeah and
yeah yeah sure and i'm going to try to
be
smart about it very sure
and go
do i want to go h4 no i'm going to go
with it and i'm going to go not smart
about it i'm just going to go if c5
perfect
and here maybe i'll get zug's wrong i
don't know but
i have you exactly where i wanted
alejandro that's great i'm going to go
h4 now and now i assume that if i play
like f3 or something like this i
eventually lose
i'm going to try to get you in the zeus
one that's a good situation yes
so
what we're talking about is c6 king to
d6 you defend the pawn and now i just
simply go king to c7 and i just wait the
funny thing is it's still a draw right i
just give up my
i just give up you give up the c6 pawn i
just get off c6 yeah but at some point
will i have h3 with the king on e3 and
you take on f3 yes
maybe maybe not maybe actually the move
f2 is just stupid
f3 sorry
let's let's let's go into that line
because this is quite
the idea being that you can never go and
this is why i play the move h4 you can
never go into h3 after king to h3 i just
give you a check followed by a1 and you
lose by the way i made a huge blunder
apparently smearing did play the 2019
spring classic he did yeah i'm gonna
make a mistake there shout out to tony
rich our organizer and overall amanda
does everything around the club
as he's informed me oh marin excellent
excellent all right so
what do we have after rook to c5 two
minutes and 46 seconds for
the youngster trying to find something
in this position it doesn't seem like
there's much no
i don't think so uh
they're closing on a move 40 so
i mean time pressure shouldn't be an
issue but i can't imagine that against
the player has experienced like a smear
and you end up winning the same game
excellent black is someone with chances
but
let's get back to this you ooh my
goodness a lot of things have changed so
after bishop to f6 we actually saw this
move a bishop to d for a move that we
were considering uh
move ago it's a stretch time to do so
trying to understand why why did he do
it in this move order because now knight
to e6 doesn't attack the bishop on g7
anymore so i have options i can order d7
which is a better version than the
previous one exactly right or i can go
take rook takes before now this is going
to be
perhaps and this is our first decisive
result of uh sergeant drop your question
yes the first decisive result of our
spring summer chess classics as dragoon
did as expected beat jealous we did not
see any defense for black in that
position uh he collapsed a little
quicker perhaps than we thought
but not too not too quick i mean
we will be having uh
mr dragon explaining his thought process
this game and this beautiful attack in
just a few minutes now oh that was a
that was a beautiful finish beautiful
absolutely and we should actually switch
to it because it was just such a such a
shorter finish at the end yeah
do we want to spoil that before he shows
yeah let's just spoil it that's fine
we're going to spoil it all right
because it's it's not so much about
so i think we got up to this position
knight b to c5 was the move we left it
at yeah and then
what the c7
automatically with evaluations knight to
d6
queen to b6
rook to g4 now setting up this beautiful
attack on the g7 square yeah g5
g5 rook to c4 roxy4 is a great move it
just turns to take on c6 and go queen e5
exactly yeah
so you're kind of getting killed but
knight d8 allows this beautiful knight
that's a very it's such a pretty move
right
by the way just be careful not to move
this rook
off the first track
because you're going to get checkmated
on g1 right that could happen that
sometimes happens right imagine this f7
juicy pawn being unprotected and you go
rook takes
f7 boom queen g1 comes on the board and
you just resign i mean isn't that what
happened to
magnus
it was magnus against stevenshire in a
blitz championship like they have a
normal position yeah and it was exactly
that there was a queen on b6 in berlin
in berlin right there was a queen on b6
there's a bishop i think there was a
bishop something defending g1 yeah and
magnus allows queen g-1 main yeah yeah
and then he threw his uh he
signed the scoresheet through his pen
and
stormed out of the building
beautiful game we're going to see the
explanation of our first victory in just
a couple of minutes now
let's get back since um
we want to pick something juicy let's
let's just finalize the assessment of
this one uh the assessment
the game between you young closer to it
closer to a draw than a win but black's
pushing absolutely all right
jumping the big group
okay we saw that three games still going
vasquez versus ontepo what's happening
in this one we were saying i mean
vasquez probably has a much simpler
position and this is exactly what we're
seeing right now on the board
this is like borderline winning the main
differentiator not necessarily being the
worst structure for black but actually
the more exposed king yeah the king is a
big issue especially with the existence
of the e pawns there are no diagonal
checks against the king on h2 but
there's a lot of
routes that you have to like worry about
this king on g7 getting chucked and
we're looking at queen g5 and f6 queen
gets to f8 somehow i mean on one minute
how many moves does he have to make one
minute 21 seconds and only three moves
to me that's not so bad but it is a
tough few moves rook d7 difficult
defense now
before he makes the the the second time
control yeah you need to find something
that's right because it's true you
probably know that if he does get the
time extra 30 minutes you're probably
going to be able to defend this one yeah
and
i'm looking at the position and we're
discussing that of course the black king
is exposed but
at the same time
the rook is defending f7 quite an
important square the queen is defending
already f6 quite an important square and
the queen could potentially if it jumps
to d6 defend all important entry squares
on the f5
quite an interesting position and we
will
actually have our interview in just a
few seconds so we're going to be
looking at
this position for the time being but
also let's take a look at the price fund
in the event in the a group we see a
very handsome price fund of 22 000
6 000 for the winner 4 000 for
second place and
finished up the podium three thousand
for third place and in the b group
we have quite a nice price fund as well
fourteen thousand dollars total with
four thousand dollars for the winner
dollars for the second place and two
thousand dollars for the third place and
we do have
the first victor of round number one
camille dragoon with us here in the
studio camille welcome to the studio and
congratulations for your victory thank
you
now tell us a bit about this game you
are starting off against uh one of the
the toughest opponents in the circuit
here in the us uh zhu zhang ciao uh what
was your strategy going into this game
i didn't really have a strategy i just
kind of chose the opening before the
game i decided that if if he goes for
paulson then i will play
the system with g3
because he he usually
plays sicilian with d6
so
this is quite quite rare
so for him he generally goes d6 at move
too yeah
and his main option i would assume is
something along the lines of the neither
maybe
yes i think so i didn't want to allow
neither though i wouldn't normally play
the alliance with bishop b5 you don't
have to tell us too much
there's a lot of games left maybe i
should but it's not a big secret
excellent and he did decide to go for
this uh idea with a g3 now explain to us
the general plans in this position
well the the play of white is pretty
simple you just play bishop g2 castle
rookie one usually those are the moves
that you always and you're going to be
focusing on on attack on the king's side
more of a strategic play how would you
describe it it depends which system
blacks chooses like for instance i was
playing this line by black many times
also and i was um playing similarly to
jujin chao but he surprised me with
bishop c5 i didn't know this line at all
so usually
the line that i was playing was 94 24 oh
knight to d4 in this position yeah
bishop c5 bishop f4
d6 queen d2
h6
rook id1 b5
bishop e3
and h6 to start bishop to g5
and we get this bishop six
bishop or bishop e6 bishop b6
and this is basically the beginning of
the theory here
like
recently also black started doing
something different here
i think uh
caruana tried to play bishop e3 and fe
i guess he said bishop to e6 yeah
something like this i don't know it is
indeed atari versus a caruana game um
and i think he does give up the pawn on
d6 and then try to play a strategy game
yeah exactly that's some compensation
structure bad bishop
um but he decided to go bishop to c5 he
surprised you played knight to b3 bishop
to a7 was he still blitzing out his
moves at this point yeah more or less
yeah i actually i didn't know what he
wants to do exactly after
bishop c5 knight b3 if he goes to a7 or
to e7 yeah and
after bishop p7 i thought that will
transpose to to somehow to the to some
theory like after f4 d6
and i i didn't know about g4 here or
king h1 maybe bishop p3 like it does
seem like there's actually quite a few
games in this position yeah it just i
have no idea what's the move order here
so he played bishop to a7 and you
decided to go king to h1 makes a lot of
sense try to go f4 now yeah where was
his big mistake
uh where did you feel like you're taking
over the initiative
when he played knight h7 he he surprised
me a lot like all the way to here you
got to fight him were you surprised that
you allowed me to play e5
uh
well yeah he was thinking here uh i i
thought that he has to go 97 that but i
don't know if he is not getting under a
huge attack here
for instance i i have a lot of moves
like one of them is bishop h6 i i don't
know how good it is we were trying to
look uh and understand what's happening
in this position
we couldn't find
the capitalizing blow in this one like
queen h4 king g7 and right yeah i
thought about that this might be simply
a repetition here but
i don't know i have also maybe moved
like
six yeah but you have to defend with
rook h8 if you take you're probably
going to get checkmated yes you are
getting trackmated um queen takes h6 or
queen to g4 followed by queen to g7
now
after rook f6 rogate shade
and then maybe you can just simply
yeah i can fall you can take on e5
somewhere and
yeah i like all my pieces like i need to
somehow
to connect the knights i guess to play
something like 94 somewhere so what if
you take there's a check that's the
problem
maybe take on f7 also
this is not really in my style
crazy position crazy position and you
were worried you say about knight to d7
or at least you couldn't see the
finalizing blow
he surprised you with knight to h7
playing uh passive let's see yeah the
advantage of knight h7 is that the king
is saved but the knight is completely
out of play
and
after that it seemed like
by the way we really like this move a4
and it did feel like you surprised your
opponent with this move oh yeah me too
actually i was really proud
of that that's a good move to be proud
of yeah i thought that this is actually
the main reason that black is in huge
trouble here now yes and we got all the
way to this position
every single piece of yours
was playing an active role into the
attack oh yeah after queen e5 when i
played bishop c3 he he seems surprised
like uh maybe he didn't see bishop c3
maybe he was thinking only about bishop
f4
and knight d6 but i thought about queen
b2 here
continue taking
yeah and that there were some ideas with
like 96 94 like i don't know how well it
works for black
absolutely but he played you played this
move bishop to c3 yeah surprised your
opponent but it looks quite like a
natural move yeah it's a very simple
play for white and all my pieces that
they're like
that they cannot
they don't have better squares basically
and
yeah i don't know how how i can improve
well i can improve only knight on b3
which i did basically after queen c7 now
probably there is knight a5
and after queen b8 there there is nice
um and after that you finished in style
let's say queen to b6
we were saying that you have to be uh
definitely careful about moving the rook
somewhere on the fy because
some mates are coming on g1 at times it
could be a
little unexpected
out of nowhere but you did find this
nice idea of
creating some more weaknesses in black's
position yeah i don't think he he can
play g5 probably he should play e5 but
also like after knight f5 it seems like
it just like
it would take longer probably too many
weaknesses uh beautiful start camille
who do you have tomorrow
i think i'm playing against brandon
brandon with the black pieces do you
have any experience against him
yes i think we played twice
i think it's one one something like this
excellent or maybe three times yeah and
it's one and a half to one and a half
quite a tight score in that one a big
matchup for you tomorrow camille we'll
let you go get some rest get some
preparation going we'll see you tomorrow
thank you
and
we're going to get straight back in to
the analysis because we still have three
games pending in the big group and uh
two games spending in the a group and
we're going to continue with this crazy
game or at least what it looked like a
crazy game a few moves ago between
chekha and
jacobson brandon because
we left it off somewhere around this
moment and we were considering this idea
of rook 28 and setting up the plan of
knight takes h3 followed by g to putting
a lot of pressure on that rook on e1 as
well as
the whole e-file now alejandro you're
back
yes i am tell us about this position
well it seems that they followed in what
we thought right because brandon did
play them with rookie eight first we
were considering taking on h3 but we
thought start with the mirror k8 it sets
up all of the difficulties for black in
a more pres for white in a more pressing
manner because that rook is attacking
only one taking on h3 and g2 sets up
discoveries so this actually seemed to
be the better way for us brandon seems
to have agreed and after
forcing this trade perhaps forcing takes
takes queen d7 played i think more of a
symptom than anything else this move
queen d7 that you have to attack the
rook get it out of the file somehow i
don't know how much it helps you because
after rookie seven
check on d8 king h7 he did go for c6
kind of bites the bullet goes c6 but it
invites all these kind of stuff with
knight takes h3 and off we go and by the
way c6 for me it actually looks like a
defensive it is a defensive move yeah i
know that it's trying to queen the pawn
which is also nice but more about
involving this bishop right this bishop
back on the on the diagonal coming back
into the game exactly so we see knight
takes h3 followed
by g2 takes on g2 the same patterns that
we were discussing rook to u1 yeah you
cannot take the rook because
made it at the end after bishop to e5
yeah i think we should be if it's just
me too
but that's the problem in the game as
well if you go king to h2 first bishop
d5 comes and now he has the move he's
played the move queen d4
this is actually very beautiful because
had he played um
queen takes h4 by the queen was hanging
the bishop he fights a beautiful move oh
oh i didn't even notice that yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah pretty exciting it's actually
super super cute bishop is such a pretty
move knight e2 or actually even knight
to h5 because yeah surprisingly even
knight h5 just wins uh wins the game
because it's actually checkmate it's
actually checkmate queen g3 or queen to
f4 followed by bishop takes f4 or
bishop takes g3 it's actually it's
actually that's nice that's nice bishop
e5 is a very unexpected and very uh
picturesque yeah move and he so he plays
bishop d4 so right now i could take
on d8
if i felt like it you could because i
just don't know if there's anything
better or there's a reason he's not
doing it he just picked up the queen he
did yeah maybe there was nothing better
though yeah i mean your queen's hanging
so queen takes d8 uh on the board and
what is the material by the way just
just
just to clarify things yeah um
what if you take on e1 where's the mate
i'm not saying there's no mate i just
want to see the main take only one here
right that's probably just knight to e2
king to h1 and queen e1 takes c1
bishop to g1 queen takes g1 very nice
and that's just a checkmate
okay so we have this bishop to d4
probably a forced move
uh to not get checkmated but queen takes
d8
physically takes e5
yeah the thing is i can i think i can
just take on d1 right no don't don't
make your life hard
you do have a c pawn i i understand that
rook takes the one by the way came on
the board 42 seconds and counting
for nico checker and to be honest
i think he's just done at this point
yeah the thing is c7 you just got queen
d2 queen to d2 you shouldn't even defend
you don't have time to go c8 queen
because you do get checkmated yeah this
game is over so a nice star there for
brandon jacobson uh beating another
strong
uh players that actually i think they're
very similar in age and by the way we do
have bishop takes a four queen to d4 not
only that i'm attacking the bishop one
e4 but also i'm hitting at the idea by
the way look at this knight on a4 such
an ugly night it never did anything it's
been an ugly night for the past
30 moves i it just didn't do anything
it's funny how one septic piece can just
destroy your position and it does not
not participating in the defense just
changes all the evaluations yeah and i
think we will probably see a resignation
after going to d4 yeah you're just done
too much material even if you aren't
getting made it you're down too much
material but
you are getting late you can see
actually on the screen is the game
between you young yi and glendura
and since this one is about to end we're
going to move to that game yeah i think
so because this is done done this is
done done done
and you young yi uh
well
newcomer to the club
that one i actually did chuck
uh
he's facing off a tough situation right
so he has a bunch of activity but
currently he's down not one but two
pawns
uh this bishop on f6 is two pawns but to
be frank rook takes h7 will come
next move actually the more i'm looking
at it i'm starting to wonder who's
playing for a win
cause i'm playing who is playing for a
win well what if i play p6 you want to
play b6 yeah you want to check me
okay so basics you do have obviously
rook to f8 coming
i probably have to defend like this yeah
because if you're a king c8 you just
lose to rook at c7 rook h7 right i i
even
rook fade almost works but it doesn't
yes yeah yeah this is just lost you're
just helping me for no reason so if you
cannot play king c8 you have to play
rook to c rook to c4
the big problem in this position for
black is that you don't have this track
on f4 so you change the x because the
knight is protecting that one
so
rook to c4 yeah i don't really have
knight c7 because of the aforementioned
rook f4
so i might have to just take on h7 take
on h7 and now let's start ah
i cannot start running because you do
have a threat right now i do have rocket
shade rectangles okay
it's just a much better position than
with the rook on the file because europe
should be said yeah
so v6
rook c4 looks for stitch
b6 has not been played and he does have
we're at move 38 right now two more
moves until they get the second second
time control
b6 seems like a natural move yeah b6 is
very natural rook c4
and then take on
um on h7 right this looks kind of forced
you could still go bishop f6 but
i mean white's not playing for a queen
so how do you
defend this position as black i don't
think you have a choice
you want to go king c8
uh maybe you want to go be specific i
wouldn't think of a bishop f6
but maybe it's just a sad sad move
i mean in a worst case scenario i have
rook f7 which forces i think i i just
don't think that black's playing for a
win anymore
no
i mean it just looks dangerous
we
might be wrong about that because we are
not using an engine but but
visually at least it looks like white's
position is is threatening wait because
look at it this way right he can go
knight c5 right now just force the draw
at what point like right now
knight to c5 that has to be a draw right
so what if i
give you a check yeah and i think i just
pick up too many points here and now if
you go here you can pick up i mean
you're not never worried about this
probably not no so you're thinking about
higher expectations from the position by
this right
right
so knight to c5
not working still thinking 40 seconds
and counting he has to make a move he
has taken decision at this point
um basics does look very very very
tempting and he actually didn't did play
the move b6 and rook c4 played instantly
as we expected that was the only move in
the position for black so let's go with
the main line take on h7 uh not bishop
to f6 but rather king to c8 and by the
way i think we are following
that variation exactly
and let's see if king to c8 is going to
come
yeah we don't like bishop f6 no no to
note that uh with this capture on h7
yuyongi has uh gained 30 minutes on the
clock because
so
that's good for him but ladura has a
minute 30
to figure out whether he wants to play
king c8 or bishop f6 i don't see
a third alternative it seems like
everything else drops the bishop and
there we go the move king c8 on the
board
absolutely and uh while we were
discussing this game actually brandon
jacobson did win um
the game i mean that we just saw an
unexpected result he did have an extra
xj uh rook yeah or something next to an
extra queen it was queen for three
pieces but then here but that makes
correct yeah yes that's quite nice to
have that extra rook uh and now we do
see this position by the way king to c8
was played i'm not sure how to evaluate
this one
and um we will have brandon in just a
second in the studio with us
i feel like i should know where he's
studying
i feel i know this it's mit right isn't
it mit i
it's one of those i'm just
throwing darts at this point
um
king to see colombia colombia there we
go we knew that
yes
we actually did that all right
so how do we
how do we continue right now after king
to c8
i wasn't so sure actually maybe we're
overestimating white's position i think
we are right because suddenly the spot
on a6 is kind of dangerous and i don't
have an immediate draw i think we are i
think um we're just kind of like being
too happy about like the usual maybe
knight c5 was correct to just draw the
game right maybe we just got tempted by
v6
maybe
no absolutely uh king to c8 and right
now they have
made the time control the second time
control they each get an extra 30
minutes and it does seem like black is
pressing black is a pawn up there's no
checkmate coming from white's
perspective now this pawn on b6 could
become a liability if um
if the bishop remains on the board and
is going to be able to attack it either
via d8 or f2 later on in the game
i do like black's position i do feel
like white potentially
is close
to finding the route to equality but i
just don't see it it's
not yet
in the position but
as we are waiting for these players uh
to uh try to understand the position and
make the right decisions we do have a
player that
made the right decisions throughout the
game that is uh brandon jacobson brandon
congratulations a big victory with the
black pieces against nikko chukka how
does that feel
great great i mean obviously i played
the the king's indian with
intention to fight so
yeah i'm glad i got an interesting game
um
now you you know nickel quite well um
you guys are the same generation more or
less have been facing each other for a
while
how did you approach this game what are
his weaknesses without revealing too
much right i mean when he gets you know
if i played like a solid qgd for example
he's very good positionally i think um
i basically have no winning chances out
of the opening like if i went for
something solid
um especially coming into tournament
like this i wanted to fight every game
so
and i think he's
the one thing i would say is he's pretty
predictable with his openings so
i was able to prepare quite deep for
this game because um he basically plays
this classical line every single game
perfect now take us through the opening
phase you say
that uh this position was likely in your
preparation yeah
oh yeah so there's this new h6 line that
um a lot of strong players have been
experimenting with but
um i think he played
pretty much like the most logical line
rookie one the idea of this h6 move is
so that after bishop e3 i can go knight
g4 now and there's no bishop g5
um so it's actually kind of
uncomfortable for white to find a move
because you don't really want to go h3
ever and then i take on d4 and then
you're gonna have to go f3 after
uh weakening up all these nice dark
squares around the king right you don't
want to do that so rookie one bishop f1
is the most logical way of playing um
rookie 8 rook b1 just sort of improving
the position yeah here it takes d4 i
don't know if it's been played before
but this was this was my preparation and
it looks like there's not really much of
a point to it like why are you delaying
it takes d4
but black actually gets a lot of counter
flight pretty quickly like with
with a6 and b5 similar to what happened
in the game
but what's pretty funny is that um
he i got this position in my in my
preparation up i got it up a full tempo
in the game
because he played bishop f4 knight e5
then f3
right and then and then a6 queen d2 but
instead of bishop f4 he can go um f3
immediately
i would go now e5 and then he can go
bishop e3 here
a6
queen d2 and then g5 here i like that so
bishop is another knife yeah i got the
position up up a full tempo from my
preparation um
so
like it looks logical for white to
provoke g5 at first with some meta five
ideas but black's really quick with b5
and gets a lot of counter airplay going
similar to what happened in the game
b3
trying to keep uh the position the
structure as it is knight to h5
where do you feel like you're taking
over the initiative right so
yeah i remember these g4 g3 ideas for my
preparation i was just trying to
calculate to make sure like it works
that all the tactics work out in this
position
um i'm not sure he should do objectively
maybe he can take the knight i wasn't
sure about gtx h2 king takes h2 uh queen
h4
king kg1 i think m9g3 queen d4 should
hold for him so i have to go bishop
takes e5 instead
uh here yeah and then i think you can go
g4 it looks kind of crazy but i don't
know but i think maybe i can even just
go like king h7 here i was trying to
calculate all these lines it's pretty
insane
for example like g takes h5
uh rook g8 bishop g2 oh man and then
maybe something like red takes g2 queen
takes you to rook g8 yep and then like
rookie two so what is what's going to
have two rooks and a piece for the queen
but i'm like collecting all those king
side pawns yeah like maybe i can
certainly give a check but there's not
actually
yeah maybe there is no take but now i
have bishop to g1 right so maybe i
should take on h5 at some point and just
try to collect all the puns and play
that position which probably shouldn't
be worse for black if i'm gonna be
up all these puns
so i was trying to make all these lines
work um
yeah so i guess he was afraid of all
this understandably um so he played h3
and he played h3 did not take the bait
the knight on e5 right
uh knight to g4 are quite
kind of a cute line by the way after
after knight g4 uh h64 yes uh queen h4
bishop e2
it looks like maybe you can make it
survive but and it takes f4 here bishop
f3 you cannot take because you get
checkmated in two moves
so you have to defend with bishop to f3
right now queen h2 turning f1 queen h1
truck bishop g1 and that h3 that's kind
of it oh that's right
yeah
that's very nice
you don't have a spot on this diagonal
to defend with the queen
you are basically forced to take on h3
and after queen takes f3 you just get
checkmated
um actually where is the checkmate
atleast when you probably just take
right
take and then take on h3
yeah
looks quite good for a black
and you guys went in this position and
this is where we kind of picked up your
game after the move c5 we're trying to
understand this move c5 now right it
doesn't make a lot of sense visually at
least because it cuts off the action of
the bishop one b6 very important
defender um
how did you assess this position i
thought instead of queen d6 he probably
had a better defense i don't know what
but i i figured that queen the queen
feels a bit awkward they're like
allowing knight d3 so maybe queen queen
f3 i would have played like knight e5
and then queen e4 for example
um and i wasn't really sure what was
going on here like i figured i probably
shouldn't be worse with all my activity
at rookie eight but the game goes on
like king h1 for example just
sidestepping any any tactics um midnight
xh3 and it's like it looks it visually
looks great for black all my pieces are
in the attack but i'm not actually sure
like how to proceed here maybe i just
play a waiting move like bishop f6
because i want to go king h7 like so
when i move my knight and he takes on ea
it's not with check
so i can't do that because f6 last move
so
just sort of improving the position and
yeah i mean it looks like a total mess i
wasn't sure what was going on here
um but i think after queen d6 and that
f2 it starts to get really really scary
for him quite dicey indeed and
especially after this move c5 you
started
following it up with a very precise move
yeah it took me a while to find rookie
because for a while i was okay so
firstly if i take on on d1 he plays rook
takes
and then if i go rookie a here for
example he goes c6
like okay probably black should be
better after bishop e5
but queen c5 for example this feels like
a total mess though the pun's getting to
c7 like if i don't have mate immediately
like his pawn is super strong in c7
um
and he has two bishops and it can go
either way absolutely um so and i was
also looking at i was trying to make
knight takes h3 work night uh two takes
we don't have the engine okay we did not
look uh at it with the engine we were
seeing this position and then we saw
your rookie 8 and we said okay rookie 8
is probably much more comfortable right
so can we go quinn d2 here yeah
according to end some
maybe bishop to d4
yeah i mean
another thing i can do instead of rookie
8 after uh
bishop takes g2
oh yeah i can get queen g3 i think this
is like yes i think this is a draw for
queen d2
bishop c3
um not bishop to d4 but yeah i think we
just go king h1 i don't really see a
follow-up there
queen c2 knight takes h3 and if kf1 i
always have queen f4 so i should just
repeat here just uh just to draw yeah so
this was sort of my my backup option if
i didn't find anything else um
and i think this is just perpetual yeah
rookie is strong because that i mean the
reason i rejected it at first like this
queen c6 looks like it just kills ricky
eight but i can take on e1 anyway
queen takes a king h7
all right just taken g2 uh bishop d4 i
think bishop to d4 right now and then
hide the king no more checks and some
checkmate is coming right knight takes
h3 followed by knight to f2 and there's
no way to defend against that
very nice very very nice and he did take
on e8 and after that it felt like smooth
sailing for you no way he's going to be
able to defend
with only the bishop on f1 against so
many of your piecing pieces coming his
way yeah by the way i didn't see like
this rookie one bishop e5 idea for a
while so my original plan was to go
queen g3
uh here yeah
queen d2 and then rookie two i mean this
i'm sure is winning too but i was
getting low on time and i was like okay
takes on e2 he goes kf1 he has a pawn on
c6 like i started panicking as king can
run if i'm not meeting him then maybe
you can go c7 at some point right but
yeah then i found rookie one very nice
this game over i think brandon uh a
great start for you ideal start with the
black pieces against one of the top
players in the event who do you have
tomorrow uh dragon i think dragoon he
started off with a win as uh well good
luck we're looking forward to see you
tomorrow great thank you
and as we were discussing this one uh
well everything is still in play
in this game between you yang yi and
gleddura and after king to c8 as we were
expecting
no move has been played
because it's a critical moment in the
game white has to find a way to
potentially equalize the game
probably not much more than that and uh
alejandro
yes what were you looking at
during your break i was fascinated by
your interview christian it was such an
exciting position that brandon had there
great against czechoslovakia great
position and there are a lot of little
details we missed right this bishop c3
actually was very interesting uh instead
of bishop default because you don't have
any squares for the queen yeah it's very
very cool
uh so here i i still think that
if this doesn't quite work
alpha white
that perhaps b6 was actually just a
mistake because perhaps we overestimated
by its position
i still think knight c5 made cut out of
easy draw
and he did think for a very long time
relative to what he had left we were
playing b6 as an automatic but it wasn't
actually an automatic um and as we were
discussing maybe this pawn on b6 is
going to become a liability
yeah i expect so
because right now if you allow my king
sorry if you allow my king to get to c6
that's a problem it's a huge problem and
how do you defend
right because white's plan is pretty
easy black spawn is pretty easy right
you you actually do just push the pawn
yes because it doesn't really matter
where it is there's no real forks or
ways to catch it no no and and
okay
all of white species are looking
threatening right yes active position
the problem is
that you don't have a great way to
relocate this knight from e6 and
whenever you give a check on the eighth
rank and allow the king to go to d7 the
knight on e6 is uh almost trapped yeah
yeah
but almost trapped it actually doesn't
have a great amount of activity no
not at all um i have to say i'm really
liking gledora's position now
this end game is going to go on for a
while um let's see what's happening in
the game between vasquez and antipov and
antipov did make the time control and he
has this position which does seem quite
close to equality
that looks like just a draw right you'll
take just a draw you'll take on e4 or
something like this i'll go
work behind the pawn somehow either with
rook d3 first or rook d3 not first i
think rook d4 okay four maybe i think
you take me e4 immediately because if
you take on a5 maybe they draw us easier
you mean at this point yeah for white
for white right you might as well take
what i think yeah take um then i think
either you'll take or you'll go to d3
first
i don't think it matters too much 35 and
i mean at this level
this should be quite easy yeah that
should be quite easy
still a little bit of work to be known
for black but well i think you put the
pawn on it i think here you put the
power in h4 because you already crossed
the fourth rank this is usually a
mistake if the point is on a4 because
then you run into the issue that the
rook might be on g4 in an extra ball you
can't actually move the rook from g4
this king on h2 would like run to the
queen side and there's very little you
can do about it
but
i can cut you you can cut me but when
the works on g4 i just continue running
right but without because it's protected
because it's protected but what's the
rook with the rokon g5 unfortunately
doesn't really work because i have k6
screen h6 and you're just going to have
to drop yeah and even if you do get h4
you don't in this line because i got g5
but even if you do it's just a dead draw
so that's the big difference that when
the pawn is on a5 the move h4 is good
before that probably not good
14 minutes for antipov 36 minutes for uh
guillermo vasquez but the position
is quite easy to handle for both sides
and most likely it's going to end up in
a draw i would be very shocked if it did
how about this end game another rooken
game uh between john burke and tigran
hartunyan
well
which could become a pawn end game
actually yeah we we were
playing with spawn uh potential pawn end
games
quite a lot actually and uh it did feel
like
despite the fact that this triple pawns
on the f5
look quite weak sometimes it might give
you an extra tempo yeah the thing is
about the tempos right so i mean i don't
really see why
i don't see why black should take ever
like i think rookie 7 is such an easy
move to play but let's assume that they
if i get this position
what do you play for a win this is just
a draw
yeah you just keep in december it's just
a trick
king d6 king c6 there's no way to to
break it
in fact
just let's just go 46 right
i mean whatever i guess this is the only
move that can
do something and then we play for a loss
probably much faster than you
yeah
not even close
so
yeah no no so it's just a draw right
it's just taking c6 and then you go b5
next move b5 and then you just keep the
king on d6 and c6 and
yeah yeah that's it
yeah now this uh
don't play king to d6 because after b5
b6 now we get into those type of
situations where i have this extra tempo
and you have two after tempe which is
important because king d5 king d7 i
still have an extra tempo f3 f3 and now
once again we get into the position that
we actually looked at
and they are indeed following the line
that we discussed king takes d4 is on
the board the exchange of the rooks and
kings 66
looks that these players are going to be
shaking hands three times yeah i agree
with that that looks like a draw to me
all right so it does seem like the more
imbalanced let's say a game still
pending is uh this one
alejandro the one between you young yi
and gledora and let's try to give it a
final assessment
i mean
black is better we know that so the
assessment that we're looking for is
how much better right can you win this
position
i have a feeling
that black
is just not doesn't have enough
resources
to actually win the game really i i have
the feeling it has to do with this
bishop on h4 being so weak okay so let's
try to take advantage of that king i was
thinking ke2 is a way to start here
and if i do continue with rook to c6 so
you are looking at ideas such as king to
d3 destabilize the rook
which has to stay also
on the c file to defend against rook to
c7 but also on the fourth rank to defend
the bishop
h4 and that's impossible yeah um so at
some point after king to d3 you will
probably have to go
to c6 now do you want to start with rook
to c6 do you want to let's say uh
disengage this bishop from
the
fighting right well what do you do with
this bishop because the bishop have sex
with f7 is just
just have to go back to h4 exactly
it doesn't really help me no so it does
seem like maybe the only way to get out
of this is and i do have a feeling that
i want to wait for you to go to uh so
you wanna play like a5 just because i
want to have this extra square on e1 for
my bishop
yeah let's assume i can get behind a5
can can be an idea king to d3 and now
rook to c6
yeah okay so let's go down the line
straight rocket
rook to c6
king d7 knight f8 and now this is kind
of a funny position because it looks
like black is losing a piece
but king e7 the rook on c6 is actually
holding on to g6 and it also looks like
there will be a check check like rick h4
king f8 check check pick up v7 but
actually your king's on g7
and after king takes a favor okay you
actually don't get my pawn nope and i
get to connect it past
winners that being said
this could be this could just be
but then i go king of six
no no i think rook a8 i think we're okay
okay
these two pawns there's quite
quite far from each other it's
theoretically a draw but it's a hard
draw it's not going to be easy it's not
an easy address i think it's a draw i'm
not going to guarantee anything but i
have to give a i have to give it a
validation i think it's a joke alejandro
yes quite uh quite a fun day i have to
say especially in the b group a lot of
decisive results and decisive results i
think the big group brought it today i
think that jacobson game was really fun
the dragon game was really fun we had a
little bit of uh
i wouldn't call him mrs but the a group
today was not the
not the most exciting you have to uh
give it to the players at the same time
this is round number one you're not
taking a lot of risks it's a lot nobody
wants to start with a loss no and this
type of event
a long tournament ahead of us
now let's look at the results in a group
alejandro
and the a group we have four draws so
far between sevilla and mishra smeared
and beer theodore jacobian oppar and
against robson and we have one game left
young against benjamin glendora where
it's definitely gledura that's playing
for the win
uh whether he's going to get there we
don't quite know it seems to be a
complex end game but we know who's
pushing it in that way it'll be a huge
win if glendra does manage to convert
that end game meanwhile in the b group
we have i believe every result now
because oh no we're still missing one
because john burke has drawn against the
grand harutonian uh that game has
finished jj ali miranda drew against
christopher you some time ago and in the
two decisive games nicolas chuckled lost
with white against brandon jacobs on
dragon one with white against joe
jianchao and we have one game remaining
absolutely and don't forget we will be
having a show for at the summer chess
classic every single day from now until
june 10th join us tomorrow here on
youtube twitch uschamps.com
for the show starting at 3 30 round
number two of the summer chess classic
will be coming off tomorrow alejandro a
pleasure to be here with you and i'll
see you tomorrow pleasure to start here
we'll be here for the next 10 days don't
miss it support this great event and
check it out come come and join us see
you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club
any reproduction or distribution of this
content without the express written
consent of the st louis chess club is
prohibited
you